au bout de ce long ruban d'un kilomètre
une première mondiale
conçu en france il s'agit d'un masque et
qui élimine les coronavirus il aura
fallu cinq années de recherche conjointe
entre l'université de lille le chu de
lille et la start up française bio
serenity pour mettre au point cette
nouvelle protection contre locaux vides
les résultats sont impressionnants
l'efficacité du masque effectivement
c'est d'avoir une action sur les virus
donc on a testé surtout en environnement
de 99 points 87 % en 20 minutes vraiment
99 points de pourcent en cinq minutes
donc c'est une performance qui
qualifiait d' excellentes en virologie
une des molécules qui entrent dans
l'innovation de la poule 6 à theix
s'appelle la cyclo dextrine c'est une
petite molécule cage qui vient
emprisonné le principe antiviral et ses
produits dont les hôtes france la
fiabilité du produit fini et tester tous
les jours une dizaine de masques sont
choisis au hasard parmi les quarante
mille conçu quotidiennement sur cette
seule ligne de production
ici on évalue et on vérifie la
filtration et la respirabilité pour la
respirabilité on envoie un flux d'air à
travers deux matches et donc on a un
calculateur nous permet de voir la
différence de pression avant et après
notre pour la filtration
on envoie des fines particules donc à
travers le mas et on a opéré le
calculateur va affronter les particules
restantes après le match les bulles
qu'on a vu douter les huiles de
paraffine donc la machine injectent des
des petites particules
donc dans le sur le match et on fait
opérer de voix requis et les fines
particules pas tout on a trop mal
à terme près d'un million de masques
devrait être assemblé sur plusieurs
chaînes de production d'abord destiné au
marché français
la commercialisation de ces masques se
fera ensuite au niveau mondial un pied
de nez sans doute au retard qu'avait
pris la france dans la dotation de
masques chirurgicaux